the
capital budget overview committee
together
i would remind everybody that this is
going out
live
to an extended audience of however many
it is so please when you talk if you are
going to talk
make sure that you press the the
microphone and the red light is showing
so that
those who are listening in
can do can hear what we are saying
i would like to call this special
meeting of the capital budget overview
committee
to
order
we only have new business we are not
going to have the minutes from the last
meeting and there is no old business
as i said it is a special meeting
to address
capital budget 22-001
department of natural and cultural
resources requests approval of the
recommendation of the cannon mountain
advisory commission to implement the
cannon mountain aerial tramway and ski
area capital improvement projects
consisting of three primary snow making
arter
water pipe replacement projects and some
necessary snow making gun and hydrant
purges hydrant purchases
a boiler system replacement at cannons
primary base lodge and the replacement
of the hall rope grip assemblies on the
cannonball quad
summit chair list to be funded in the
amount of 450 000 by the canter mountain
improvement fund as specified in the
request dated january 21st
is there anybody from
the department who wishes to speak and i
will say this that you are very
fortunate
that there is another meeting at 9 45 to
which most of the members here have to
be
otherwise i would have not acceded to a
special
request for a meeting that is not our
fault because you
[Music]
got your act together so late
thank you
my name is sarah stewart i'm
commissioner of the department of
natural and cultural resources and i am
here this morning to extend my sincere
appreciation for your time this morning
we do recognize that we
were late
and there is no excuse
so thank you very much for your time um
we're here to answer any specific
questions uh with me is the manager of
franconia nacho state park and cannon
mountain john de vivo and our business
questions from everybody on the
committee
so my question is as a business
how does this place shape up
what does it look like for revenue oh
for canon yeah that would be great um do
you want to turn to let's turn to chris
moreno
good morning chris moreno chief of
administration um thanks for the
question so
uh canon mountain in terms of just
general business function is actually
doing very well
uh we we expect to close this year
actually up
uh
adding to the balance fund relative to
last year so
the in terms of revenue generation it's
really doing very well we're maintaining
a good
uh income
and we're controlling the costs as well
so
up to this point in time particularly
for this year we're actually very
pleased with the fact that we've been
able to
continue to grow the account balance
so the revenue exped exceeds the costs
by
how much for this particular fiscal year
we estimate the revenue to exceed the
costs somewhere
in the half million dollar range
okay for this fiscal year
representative the verge thank you mr
speaker um i'm looking at the time frame
given the project
uh when do you estimate this uh
project to be completed
i want to defer that to jd the mountain
manager
good morning sir thanks for the question
for the record i'm john devivo general
manager at cannon mountain aerial
tramway and ski area and franconiana
state park
the pipe project right now is out to bid
of course pending approval
both here and yesterday at the governor
executive council meeting which we did
receive
the boiler project is being looked at by
a couple of different vendors as we
speak and the grip assembly project and
installation
is actually a purchase that would go
through
das and doppelmeyer because this would
be a
sole source and a proprietary grip
assembly program is already aware and
has placed an order again pending
approval
follow up
so i mean you're looking at to be
completing this project
given that everything is goes well by
before
a certain date or september november
late november is the goal for all three
so you already have what if we turn you
down and you've already gone to governor
and council
that would be fairly unique from my own
perspective i hadn't haven't seen
anything like that before i do thank you
for uh for seeing us on short noticed uh
we literally were unable to pull a
quorum together uh at the catamount
advisory commission in april and we're
representative bucco
thank you mr chairman
um i'm looking at the uh rope grip
assembly uh that's that sounds like a
safety issue there that it's right at
the end of its
useful life
it needs to be they need to they need to
be changed this year
yeah so typically those come off and we
do 20 inspection each year
uh and we've been doing that and making
repairs and and changing the assemblies
themselves but we do want to replace
those and they were due for this year
further questions
seeing none what is the pleasure of the
committee
senator reagan i moved to approve
senator reagan moves to approve
representative clutier seconds the
motion is there any further discussion
on this item seeing none all those in
favor of approval of item cap
22-0-1-1
signify by saying aye aye opposed nay
the eyes have it and the motion is
approved
thank you very much
that is all of our business for the
capital budget overview committee
our next scheduled meeting is for monday
september 19 2022 for any of the
agencies that may be listening in
um
do it sooner rather than later because
we're going into the election season
and
we want to get this done thank you very
much
let's see
all right let's sort out who we need
here
okay everybody just sit there
you